soft boss Kitty's soft pass I bet you  can't wait to get your pass on this  exclusive clip from Puss in Boots The  Last Wish there is no way I'm letting  you hold that map Write meow  the Wishing Star is in here somewhere  Kitty may I please see the map now  seriously you won't let me hold it for  even one minute nope not even for one  second come on Kitty you've got to trust  me  wait wait what's what's going on with  his eyes oh they're getting bigger oh  Kitty  trust him look at those eyes really  you're called that cute no oh look at  her those eyes are even bigger than  yours do whatever she wants puss wait a  second  no with the pause come on  what the heck it's all so cute  foreign  can we look at the map now  am I doing  a hernia